even in gamers row tell me about that
experience because that's such a huge
show isn't it was just amazing that was
certainly a career high life it was just
everything was so big I mean the
director down million he had come
straight from doing a Desperate
Housewives and that other one there'd be
blood True Blood and it was just working
with people like James Carville
legends you know complete legend it was
it was wonderful it was really a
wonderful experience and the sets were
just amazing just blew me away from a
movie yeah need weeding any location
shooting in that as well
yeah was only up and shot in Belfast and
I mean the dan just walked out one day
when we come through the tunnel and we
walk out when in a winter land and he
just said there were two big hills and
he decide he said I want this wife I
don't want this way and these trucks
come in and they just sprayed everything
with his snow which creeps when he
walked and it was like real snow it's
just amazing some kind of amazing
experience to take with you isn't it oh
absolutely I mean it's an actor's dream
you know really is an actor's dream to
work with these people you know I mean
it's the top of the tree
what's your favorite thing about your
role in that TV series and the fact that
he's probably coming back it was just
the whole experience you know it's they
they've treat you which I'm
uncomfortable about you know once said
and started to rain and I was chaptered
some of the extras and they come over
and we come to the greenroom nice and
I'll chat with the guys here and what
we'd like you to come to the greenroom
and then I said no I'm okay I'm chatting
with the guys here so somebody came over
and holds an umbrella beside you and
people are looking and saying oh look at
that tool over there is won't even hold
his own umbrella but what they're doing
in fact is they're minding the costume
they don't care about you it's just the
costume
what would you like to see happen next
hold I'll actually have a knife that
actually might care to come back into it
it's just this if there's some of these
wretches of your dollar
you know the stories the characters
every one of them are fleshed out it's
just a wonderful show
you